sie sollen schneller effizienter und
leistungsstärker als normale computer
sein
mit ihnen könnten wir den ursprung des
universums genauer erforschen und die
simulationen durchführen die in ihrer
komplexität weit über die heutigen
möglichkeiten hinausragen
die idee der kranken computer gehört
wahrscheinlich zu den
vielversprechendsten technologien der
kommenden jahrzehnte
aber wie viel an diesem hype ist
wirklich dran
und wie funktioniert überhaupt so einen
quantencomputer
[Musik]
genauso wie letztes mal auch baut auch
dieses dritte video auf den vorherigen
auf heute schauen wir uns nämlich eine
besondere quantentechnologie die
quantencomputer genauer an
um den inhalt von heute besser verstehen
zu können hilft es euch die letzten
beiden videos dieser serie gesehen zu
haben
die links dazu findet ihr wie immer um
hier oder unten in der video
beschreibung wozu brauchen wir also
quantencomputer sind die heutigen
computer die wir bereits haben nicht
schnell genug
langsam aber sicher nähern wir uns der
mindestgröße unserer transistoren den
kleinsten bestandteilen jedes heutigen
prozessors ab einer gewissen größe
würden diese transistoren den gesetzen
der quantenmechanik derart ausgesetzt
sein dass eine vorhersehbare
funktionsweise einer unmöglich werden
würde
und wenn man sich nicht mehr auf den
zustand eines transistors also null oder
eins verlassen kann kann man sich auch
nicht mehr auf das ergebnis einer
berechnung verlassen
dieses ende des motion gesetzes ist
übrigens auch gar nicht mehr so weit
entfernt
bereits 2022 sollen transistoren bei
einer größe von unter fünf nanometern
ihre kleinstmögliche praktische größe
erreichen
genau dann soll die quantentechnologie
einspringen können dieses limit
durchbrechen und sogar noch mehr
rechenleistungen aus dem gleichen
häufigen materie herausholen können nach
dem prinzip wenn man sie nicht bekämpfen
kann dann schließe dich ihnen an mit
hierfür die ehemalige begrenzung durch
die quanteneffekte einfach für die
berechnung selbst genutzt
[Musik]
wie soll man sich das jetzt also
vorstellen
am besten vergleichen wir hier für einen
modernen klassischen computer mit einem
heutigen quantencomputer
denn prinzipiell funktionieren sie beide
auf eine sehr ähnliche art und weise
jeder normale prozessor besteht aus
milliarden kleiner schalter den
transistoren die einen fluss von
elektronen regulieren ist der schalter
offen wird dieser fluss unterbrochen und
der transistor befindet sich im
ausgeschalteten zustand in der
computersprache und dieser zustand auch
als 0 dargestellt ist der schalter
jedoch geschlossen können die elektronen
hindurchfließen und der transistor
befindet sich somit im eingeschalteten
zustand was dann auch als 1 dargestellt
wird
einer dieser zustände alleine welche als
mit bekannt ist ist natürlich nicht
wirklich nützlich ordnet man sie jedoch
auf eine bestimmte art und weise an und
lässt sie so zusammenarbeiten dann kann
man ab einem gewissen punkt sehr
komplexe informationen darstellen und
verarbeiten
je mehr transistoren ein prozessor also
hat desto mehr daten können verarbeitet
werden
bei quantencomputern funktioniert das
ganze relativ ähnlich anstelle eines
bits hat man einen so genannten
quantenbit oder auch einen jupiter
dieser crew wird kann aber sehr viel
mehr als unsere herkömmlichen witz was
beim bit mit einer schaltung
bewerkstelligt wird lässt sich bei einem
cupid in vielseitige art und weise
darstellen
zum beispiel könnte man den spin eines
teilchens also ab oder down zur
repräsentation von 10 heran nehmen das
gleiche wäre aber auch mit der
polarisation eines photons möglich
letztendlich wird genauso wie bei den
meisten anderen quantentechnologie das
gesetz der super position ausgenutzt
hierbei ist es egal welches paar an
zuständen eines teilchens genutzt wird
so lange es einen super positions-
zustand davon gibt ein cupid ist nämlich
erst dann eine 1 oder 1 0
sobald es aktiv ausgewertet wird wir
erinnern uns der effekt der super
position kollabiert sobald ein
quantenteilchen gemessen wird ist der
cube wird also unbeobachtet befindet er
sich in der super position zwischen 1
und 0
er ist quasi an uns gleichzeitig
ausgeschaltet
und wieso ist die super position jetzt
relevant
während ein herkömmlicher computer
aufgaben nach und nach abarbeiten kann
einen quantencomputer viele aufgaben
parallel berechnen dann die kuh wird
sich vor dem auswertungs prozess in
einer super position befinden existiert
bereits jede mögliche variationen eine
antwort der kranken computer müsste also
eben nicht jede berechnung neu anstellen
sondern hätten sie bereits erledigt so
lange ein ähnlicher prozess davor
stattgefunden hat natürlich wäre ein
quantencomputer zum beispiel für eine
matte hausaufgabe völlig unnötig ein
zeitlicher unterschied für ein paar
einfache matheaufgaben wäre nicht
wirklich merkbar würden wir jedoch
berechnungen betrachten für die ein
heutiger supercomputer eventuell ein
paar tage monate oder sogar ein paar
jahre brauchen würde
dann erscheint die möglichkeit der
quantencomputer aktionen schon gleich
viel attraktiver denn setzt die heutigen
prototypen können manche aufgaben
millionenfach schneller erledigen
quantencomputer sind meister in dem was
wir schon länger bei klassischen
computern erreichen wollen
sie sind extrem effektiv in der
parallelen berechnungen bei modernen
computern haben wir führen diese
eigenschaft bisher immer unsere
prozessoren in sogenannte course
unterteilt bestimmt habt ihr schon
einmal irgendwas mit quad oder dual core
bei einer produktbeschreibung gelesen
je mehr cores ein klassischer computer
hat umso besser kann er einen prozess in
kleinere aufgaben unterteilen und bei
quantencomputern müssen wir genau das
eben nicht mehr machen
die parallelität ist quasi schon in den
cubes eingebaut
kein wunder also dass bereits 20 bis 50
jubels leistungen in gewissen bereichen
erzielen können an die kein normaler
prozessor mit milliarden an digitalen
bezahlen kommen könnte
in der theorie klingt das natürlich
alles sehr verlockend aber wie ist denn
so ein quanten prozessor in der realen
welt aufgebaut
auch hier kann man wieder zahlreiche
ähnlichkeiten feststellen
die transistoren eines klassischen
prozessors bilden der mit sogenannten
gatter welche logische operationen
ausführen können der sich in der schule
oder in der uni schon mal mit logik
beschäftigen musste sollte zum beispiel
das mathematische und oder das
mathematische oder bereits kennen neben
diesen sogenannten and und ohr
schaltkreisen gibt es bei klassischen
computern noch die note nur und
namensvetter welche letztendlich einfach
nur die negation also umkehrungen
darstellen mit diesen daten lassen sich
dann sogenannte module zusammen bauen
welche simple operationen die
multiplikation und co übernehmen können
diese module können dann natürlich
selbst wiederum zusammengebaut werden um
zunehmend komplexere aufgaben zu
übernehmen und zu suchen sind quasi wie
ein lego baukasten für computertechnik
bei einem quantencomputer gibt es
ebenfalls genau solche götter anders als
bei den klassischen elektrischen
schaltungen unserer herkömmlichen
prozessoren haben quanten gatter jedoch
ein anderes ziel
anstatt der weiterleitung eines
elektronisch stroms gibt es bei ihnen um
die physikalische manipulation der cubes
zb gibt es da das sogenannte hadamar
skater mit welchem sich ein cupid zurück
in eine super position versetzen lässt
dieses hadamars katar stellt hierbei ein
sogenanntes 1 cupid katar dar welches
nur den wert eines keywords manipuliert
logischerweise gibt es auch zwei kilo
wird uns drei schaltungen das controlled
oder auch seenotretter beispielsweise
mit hilfe von quanten verschränkungen
zwei akkus werden hier immer zwei
gleiche bild werte ausgegeben oder das
deutsch kater bei welchen die zustände
von zwei qubits den letztendlichen
zustand eines dritten bestimmen könnte
so kompliziert sie auch klingen mögen
mit den zahlreichen möglichen kranken
gattern lassen sich letztendlich die
gleichen module erstellen wie sie
bereits in jedem heutigen computer
verwendet werden rückblickend wird hier
der tragende unterschied zwischen tubes
und spitz erst wirklich relevant jedes
quanten modul berechnet alle möglichen
ergebnisse des schaltkreises
gleichzeitig und nicht nur das eine was
gerade gebraucht wird
und genau diese eigenschaft skaliert
sich mit der anzahl der verfügbaren
cubes noch einmal exponentiell ist an
dem hype also wirklich etwas dran
quantencomputer werden uns sehr
wahrscheinlich in einigen spezifischen
bereichen gewaltige fortschritte
ermöglichen
sie werden aber nicht unsere bisherige
art der komplikation ersetzen sondern
vielmehr in den bereichen ergänzen in
denen sie noch verbessert werden könnte
das heißt vor allem aufgaben die heute
noch als sehr rechenintensive
abgestempelt werden könnten in einer art
hybrid system viel einfacher bewältigt
werden
unter anderem zählen zu den möglichen
anwendungsbereichen zum beispiel die
simulation komplexer systeme
ironischerweise könnten quantencomputer
gerade mit simulationen der
quantenmechanik für einige fortschritte
sorgen wodurch die quantencomputer
selbst wiederum noch besser werden
könnten
aber auch bekannte gebiete wie die
molekularbiologie mit ihren unzählbar
vielen konfigurationen verschiedener
moleküle könnte von solchen simulationen
ziemlich profitieren ein anderes
mögliches anwendungsbeispiel wäre aber
auch die kryptographie die wir bereits
im letzten video zur quantentechnologie
angesprochen haben
quantencomputer wäre nämlich in der lage
unsere heutigen verschlüsselungs
vorgänger völlig wertlos zu machen
aber zum glück gibt es ja noch die
möglichkeit der quantenkryptografie um
die selbst quantencomputer nicht darum
herumkommen hürden mehr dazu gab es aber
wie bereits gesagt schon im letzten
video
letztendlich bietet sich dann noch die
anwendung im bereich der datenbanken
besonders mit dem aufkommen riesiger
datenmengen die man auch als big data
bezeichnet wird eine schnelle
suchmethode dringend benötigt
quantencomputer könnten solche
datenbanken in einem bruchteil der sonst
benötigten zeit durchsuchen und so für
eine viel effektivere arbeitsweise
sorgen
eines ist auf jeden fall sicher wir
stehen immer noch an den anfängen einer
computer technischen revolution bei
welcher unsere bisherigen schaltkreise
noch nicht einmal ansatzweise ein
mögliches limit stoßen denn auch die
zahl der cubes in unseren
quantencomputern wird wie bei bisherigen
prozessoren exponentiell wachsen
irgendwann wird der tag kommen an dem
man quantencomputer eine aufgabe lösen
kann
die kein klassischer rechner
physikalisch bewältigen könnte ein
zeitpunkt der unter dem namen der
quantum supremacy bereits erwartet wird
das war das dritte video meiner serie
zum thema quanten falls euch fragt warum
ich nicht an meinem üblichen youtube
said bin ich bin hier im magnetlabor des
forschungszentrum jülich und an diesem
gerät hier hinter mir wird gerade an
transistoren für quantencomputer
geforscht ich habe mir gedacht das ist
ganz passend und durfte netterweise hier
drehen deswegen an dieser stelle vielen
dank an professor thomas schäfers danke
auch an das bundesministerium für
bildung und forschung für die
unterstützung bei der produktion und
danke an euch fürs zuschauen
falls ihr eines der bisherigen beiden
videos verpasst habt findet ihr noch
einmal alle gesammelt in einer playlist
unten in der video beschreibung
ansonsten diskutiert gerne mit mir unten
in den kommentaren über die zukunft der
quanten in unserem alltag und ansonsten
wie immer bleibt neugierig
[Musik]